foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the break room we were
we were like jug banding it there just
for a second uh This Is The Daily Show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news you need to know
live from New Rockstar's actual break
room here in our Los Angeles studio uh
we're thrilled to be here with you
coming up on today's show there's a
quick a quick tease of the fun things
we're gonna do first off koigandro who's
who's at the opposite end of the table
there padded and and happy uh is gonna
do a five minute or less recap of
everything we know about the secret
Invasion show okay
um he's he's prepped he um he's gonna
break the sound barrier with how fast it
possibly we don't know but we're very
excited for that also we'll be covering
Maya Hawk would love to return for robin
as Robin in stranger things five but
she'd also uh do a Robin Steve spin-off
and she might want her character to die
it took me she's like just kill me just
kill me
a little bit to be like she's playing
Robin like Batman Robin I literally I
was like
you corrected me I mean maybe she would
also like that thirsty thespian we don't
know uh speaking of uh the bat Universe
Brendan Fraser Pokemon at Batgirl
cancellation we've got a clip uh the
Mandalorian end game plans are confirmed
by Katie Sackhoff uh kid Harrington
addresses his MCU future as Black Knight
and it's not what you think we also have
a clip for that uh um and finally we'll
be finishing off with a mandatory fun
round of She-Hulk episode 5 predictions
that episode comes out tonight we'll all
be watching it uh Coy will be watching
it possibly Under the Influence as
tomorrow's his birthday
really
birthday
I didn't learn from someone else's
mistakes it's so scary it's so exciting
oh wow look at that wow look at you
you'll meet you'll be pulling out pieces
of confetti
yeah that's absolutely right yeah I used
to work as a party princess you'll be
finding those in crevices
um now Anna you mentioned uh something
on a very different note earlier yes yes
I when I talk about the Redemption for
today because
something spooky is happening at the new
rock star's office for some reason when
the moon is full and high in the sky on
the other side of the world it's just
the sun here but when it's high on the
other side of the world
something a little spooky happens when
the Super Chat reaches 100 dollars
someone in the office
turns into a werewolf
I know thank you thank you Jessica for
the backup
when that happens don't worry for your
safety and for our safety the rest of us
will kill them it's the only appropriate
thing what if I'm the werewolf
um we'll take good care of you if you're
the werewolf okay who knows who knows
who it will be it's been affecting
everyone around here so uh we've killed
a lot of people
some false positives we're in that mix
too a couple folks did not uh turn uh
but you know what trash bags in the chat
Breakers roomies uh don't you know what
it's not worth it it's not worth the
risk to any of our safeties do not give
us any Super Chat money it's just not
worth it okay please stop somebody
already did match 143 from Canada this
sounds like something a werewolf would
be saying someone that is disguised as a
werewolf what
I'm not werewolf
should I have to sit next to him today
anyways let's flesh out those
headlines yes
we didn't get injured no one knows who
we are right now oh I'm sorry thank you
Anna thank you
yeah
I appreciate it
um yeah that's I did I cued you to do
your part before I did my part uh of
course I already mentioned Coy's here
Jessica Clemens is here she'll be
breaking down that episode of She-Hulk
that drops uh tonight on Disney plus and
then uh the wonderful Anna vanston is
here to keep me honest not to mention
anything I missed and then just off
camera we've got a lurking uh smirking
forgot I gotta take this at the birthday
party oh no I'm pretty sure Tommy was
patient
s
we're worried about werewolves oh God if
there's werewolves okay uh let me know
yeah that's okay Tommy's actually can't
be on the show today not for his normal
illegal reason but uh not guilty he's
actually doing a really exciting project
that we're excited about at new
rockstars that hopefully we'll be able
to show off some on the break room
sometime soon uh so but he might pop in
and disrupt things whenever possible
fast I can get these done okay okay he
might join us for the back half of the
episode break room uh impossible uh
never been done
um but oh first headline yeah uh this is
actually late breaking news I didn't
even tease this to the top we you know
here on the break room we're on Barbie
watch 2022. okay
is that what it stands for
um
[Applause]
that actually works a lot better
Saoirse Ronan did an interview where she
confirmed she will not be able to appear
in the Barbie film she had some conflict
she was she's working on another movie
she wanted to and apparently they had a
part set for her now of course why does
this matter she's made two movies with
Barbie writer director Greta Gerwig two
pretty good movies in
um Blackbird and Little Women right and
so they're kind of like Lady Bird Lady
Bird when he's a black bird I was like I
don't remember that word
Apple TV show right now yeah she plays a
murderer no uh and so like you know a
lot of people have been speculating that
she'd appear in this movie a little
known doll yes we're in Brooklyn but
whatever yeah
she's born in Brooklyn
[Music]
yeah when she was like 12 or 10. okay so
okay because I Googled her in one day
and it was like born Brooklyn I was like
Brooklyn Brooklyn
it's like Kobe Bryant was born in Italy
oh he's an Italian uh yeah uh his dad
was playing in New York who would have
thought who would have thought we would
have gotten to this point okay uh back
to the headlines
we'll be covering all Barbie related
news
we are very excited for that of all the
movies released next year it's easily in
our top six okay as far as excitement
level simulu come on the show discuss
your role in the Barbie film please uh
bye next headline in an interview with
rolling stone Maya Hawk uh tease The
Stranger Things spin-off
and and we don't know if this is just
her being a thirsty thespian and like
trying to put it into the ether right
like hey you know it would be fun
um she said normally it wouldn't really
be a proponent of a spin-off but if I
got to do it with Joe keery who of
course plays Steve uh and they're often
paired together in in teams or side
quests or whatever on that show I would
do anything she said she don't know
uh conversely she also wants her
character to die in the season finale
um so I guess you could die in the
season finale and maybe do like a
prequel series
why can't I I hope I hope they take that
to heart they're like she's voluntarily
like just kill me and it's like yeah I
want you to kill one of the kids even if
it has to be the teenager there needs to
be some repercussions
no he's not we can talk about why
not I remember where Steve started and
I'm not gonna forgive him for it oh oh
he's still scarred from season one Steve
he has gotten better he evolved he's
matured just kill Steve just kill stuff
did anybody else we we should have
talked about this when it happened did
anybody else see that volume of chest
here coming from Steve yeah really that
was a lot more than I expected he has a
lot of hair on his head so I assumed
everywhere voluminous yes
um during his press tour for the whale a
film that's getting a lot of awards Buzz
Brendan Frazier uh poked a little fun at
the bad girl cancellation and to be fair
we do have a clip of this to be fair
he's he was in Batgirl so he's not like
making fun of other people he's kind of
you know playing along with the joke uh
yes can we roll that clip John
Batgirl oh
[Laughter]
inside voice inside voice
okay okay I don't think that clip had
any contacts
oh I'm on the wrong camera hi uh it's
been a long day uh for context it's so
funny he was asked what uh his next
project was following the whale and he
said Batgirl okay thank you
very relevant yes and that's why he
laughs right because he's like in on the
joke that that movie's not coming out so
that's cool that was not his next
practice
play that clip for everything why not I
just want the stare
uh he's doing good
um Joker falia do the Joker sequel
that's uh currently underway uh
announced a cast Jacob Laughlin an actor
who is uh from The Maze Runner films hmm
I'm not too familiar with his work but
uh as it but he's going to be playing a
key Arkham Asylum role The Hollywood
Reporter says the actor has been cast
and uh will be an inmate at the Asylum
Who develops a relationship with Arthur
Arthur Fleck The Joker I love that type
casting like I don't know he looks he
looks like it's gonna be a real good
role he even kind of speaking of
stranger things doesn't he look a lot
like a similar face shape and whatever
to I was gonna say number one right
now or whatever yeah yeah
um
just real quick obviously way too early
speculation who do you think he could be
playing right well because he's got a
mischievousness in his eyes and also
like Joker Riddler is a great duo in the
comic books like when they play off each
other uh so I think if you're gonna make
uh you know we assume penguin with
Brennan Gleason we've got some ideas
obviously about the Harley element but I
don't I think there needs to be like
some Brotherhood so maybe Riddler
um too young to be Harvey
um well and he's he's an inmate yeah
yeah I wish I guess Harvey dead
depending on where we are in the
storyline
oh unless we are doing bad him but him
is older than that child that was a
young that was a young man I believe the
actor is born in 1996 how does that math
change oh God he's almost the same age
27 to my dad uh yeah interesting I like
that they're starting to flesh out of
koi you've long been proponent of this
like uh Rogues Gallery kind of a thing
it's a great way to do an else world
right like you've got your established
Batman Universe and another one at DC
right now as it stands but with Joker
you can really play around with these
characters in all the way is this like
DC Black Label version and you can cast
these actors that might not want to be
tied to 10 films like I think Brandon
Gleason if he's penguin that's a great
one-off where Brandon Gleason's like oh
I can play but I'm not beholden to this
for you know a decade of my life and I
think that's how you're going to get
these you know super thespians to get to
like play these roles that we want to
see them as without you know sacrificing
their other movies yeah I think is a big
issue I think I think locking down
actors is going to get more and more
tricky yeah especially with all these
competing franchises wanting uh your
soul right I also want to know about
that actor Kenny Singh that's the thing
is I'm like watch him just be a Broadway
baby yeah this is a really good scene
let's get some Jonathan Groff they're
getting Joker good singers walking can
sing yeah you can he wanna he almost won
an Academy Award yeah that's right it's
Johnny Cash okay we know he's got that
lower register okay uh in an interview
with variety Boca tan actress Katie
Sackhoff revealed that the creatives
behind the Mandalorian already have an
end in sight uh she said you know I have
been told but we'll just have to wait
and see if that happens uh the good
thing with Dave and John referring to
Dave filoni and John Favreau is that
they're constantly expanding this world
and I don't think that Star Wars fans
will be lacking for Content anytime soon
so though the Mandalorian might end
obviously Star Wars ain't ending as long
as that caches are flowing maybe you
would have money you would have money
yeah but I I actually really like that
there's an end in sight that they're not
just gonna like keep doing the show
until people lose interest they're like
no there's like a full story like in the
show while it's at its peak I think I
think three to five seasons for
Mandalorian to be great yeah oh yeah and
give me that would already be yeah so
maybe four because I don't think they'd
go like oh I think that announces the
last season before they just start
putting up maybe four to five seasons
yeah absolutely uh and then finally
talking Josh Horowitz from happy sad
confused kit Harrington addressed his
MCU future as Black Knight I think we
have a clip here let's see how loudly
out of context
uh I again and this is true I don't know
much of what they're planning and and
you know I hope to be involved in future
stuff with that character with Dane
Whitman and and that he might go on and
be the thing that everyone quote me in
the street but
I honestly don't know I don't know what
their plans are I know they're going
into a kind of phase five and you don't
know if you're going to spend more time
with mahershala or Harry Styles you
don't know I don't know I know that you
know obviously Marshall's voices came in
at the end of
eternals but you you just don't know
where they'll take it and and really and
I mean this genuinely people never
believe you when you say this but they
don't tell us much really and I think
for good reason because we'll be in an
interview like this and we'll go and
spill the beat
okay so there's a bunch in that short
clip do we think he's being honest that
he has no idea when he's next gonna
appear as black right I think he knows
the next but I don't think he knows
details I believe him that he might not
know details but I think you know
because because they're in theory
starting to shoot blade if not already
in production right that movie comes out
next year according to Patton Oswald
they got into journals too like you know
that that's what we're in a rich day
being written so I think he'd know well
I think I think he'd know where he's
needed and I don't know if he's I mean I
would be stupid not to put him in Blade
but I also don't maybe he's not going to
be in Blade and with you know we got man
thing in World finite and to me that's
setting up a great midnight Sun's
undercurrent darkness and Dan Whitman to
do very well in that world if they want
to have these team movies it feels like
they looked at the MCU and we need more
team movies and I feel like if you want
like an R-rated or very hard midnight
ask you'd want Dan Whitman so I I feel
like he knows something but he's very
clever in going like but not too much
right I don't know I feel like he
doesn't really know anything but I also
feel like a lot of them don't know would
you say that he knows nothing Jon Snow
oh yes okay
um I I assume and then the second thing
I was that's what he means like I think
they will shout at me in the streets
because you know that's all that's
getting shouted at him now right is You
Know Nothing Jon Snow
um yeah I don't know how much I believe
him though if his appearance in Blade is
like a one scene Cameo they can shoot
that in an afternoon and like but if
he's making a significant appearance in
an MCU property like that means months
and months of planning and schedules
have to line up because there's lots of
people's projects and calendars and
stuff like that you would think he would
at least have a hint of like hey keep
February 2023 oh he knows the title but
not the details I think it's like
somewhere in the middle I think he knows
when he's needed yeah but maybe not know
what it is because I mean I'm not saying
he's the level of Tom Holland but they
didn't tell Tom Holland what the script
was in a lot of infinity War like a lot
of the times when I was like this is
because he's figuring it up real time so
like I don't think it's to that level
but Marvel's secrecy meets scheduling
there's going to be a new middle ground
and I think that's what we're looking at
yeah and and maybe you know honestly
maybe his contract is like hey whatever
you're doing Drop it when Marvel calls
you know what I mean you'll make time
for this yeah think he talked a lot in
that interview which I'm actually more
surprised about because I feel like kit
should be good at not giving away a lot
of details because of Game of Thrones I
feel like he has to be good at being
like nope lips lip Shield can't talk
yeah can't talk we've got some uh we had
some polls that we got the answer to
regarding the headlines do we want to go
over there yes oh me and the one who has
very terrible oh okay here I'll set you
up uh would you we ask would you watch a
robin and Steve stranger things spin-off
64 saying yes which is a plurality
though not an enthusiastic one I'm
surprised that 36 percent of people are
like pass
um there's more you Seasons to watch uh
on Netflix Oh that great you uh another
uh do you think Jacob Laughlin will play
a villain from Batman's Rogues gallery
or a new character and again almost 50
50 Batman villain versus new character
yeah that I mean thus far the first
Joker movie didn't really feel too
beholden to the Canon or the lore right
yeah
um and then finally do you think we will
see black knight in Phase five okay
resoundingly 84 saying yes yeah it feels
like he's got to show up a little bit I
set up characters and not paying off pay
him off this is very much a setup role
like that entire it's not like we got
some of it that was literally a he had
like three scenes at the beginning and
one season at the end and then powers
are coming yeah oh gosh we're also we're
um we're about a little more than
halfway mark to um the Moon Rising the
hundred dollar donations coming in and
I'm getting more and more nervous we
have our knife nearby ready uh please
please also the MJ 2997 I see your Super
Chat kill Zack please but only if he was
a werewolf nice thanks a lot MJ I'm glad
you put that caveat in there that's
reasonable only if you're a werewolf I'm
not a werewolf we're gonna Salem which
child is and I think we just kill him I
think we just kill him somebody's a
werewolf here preemptive but it's not me
but it's not me it's not me no I guess
we'll have to get to 100 bucks to figure
that out okay uh again we got so much
great stuff coming out of d23 last
weekend Coy was there in person Eric
Voss Tommy Bechtel Brandy Barrack we're
all there in person watching that
exclusive uh video seeing those trailers
all that cool stuff
um and one kind of Marvel property we
got a lot of new information about in
the first trailer for was secret
Invasion which we're really jazzed for
that's the next series one She-Hulk raps
that's the next Disney plus Marvel
series early next year or like spring
next year I don't think we've gotten an
exact date
um but we kind of wanted because oh no
no there it is oh no
[Applause]
[Applause]
wow thank you Emerson white Tanisha
nasty feeling okay
um my teeth feel bigger is that normal
yeah okay on koi's birthday
happy birthday
definitely wouldn't want that to happen
again
um okay uh but uh so uh also on Monday's
break room episode if you haven't seen
go back and watch uh Coy Brandon and
Tommy did an awesome job they recapped
everything we learned at b23 in in under
five minutes that was even with Tommy
doing some dumb vamping at the end
um so we thought let's bring that format
back because there's a lot out there now
about secret Invasion we wanted to put
it on all in one place so koi is going
to break down everything we know about
the secret Invasion Series in under five
minutes I feel like he could probably do
it another four I have full confidence
in him but we do have a clock
producer John can we throw that on the
screen
oh oh [ __ ] it's running okay
there's an earth that we know about
is the scroll that escape Carol that was
in the subway and Captain Marvel and a
scroll working with the FBI was sent by
Nick Fury to get Monica to the saber
stay station in one division post credit
scene likely this will tie into the
Marvels rather than the secret Invasion
so depending on Ann Roadie has known
about the scroll Invasion for at least
15 years at this point in the MCU Olivia
Coleman is playing special agent Sonya
fallsworth who could be related to James
Montgomery fallsworth AKA Union track we
did meet Union Jack as part of the
Howling Commandos in Captain America the
First Avenger and Olivia Coleman could
very well be taking up that very mantle
now Amelia Clark is also rumored to be
playing either the scroll queen veronkey
or skrull secret agent yeah now it
wouldn't be surprised and that wouldn't
surprise me if they just sort of
combined those characters because Marvel
is want to do that especially with
storylines like Civil War so that's it
for things we know which isn't very much
at this point in the MCU on the other
side in the comic books when Princess
varanki receives a prophecy predicting
the annihilation of the scroll home
world the Scrolls infiltrate Earth after
their planet is destroyed by Galactus
but the whole thing is really kicked off
when viranki brings Tony Stark the dead
body of Elektra Elektra who has really
been a strong posture this whole time it
was a really beautiful imagery it tied
directly into the Daredevil death
Electro storyline and it worked really
well now why would she out the Scrolls
it was basically to make everyone super
paranoid which up the stakes both in the
comic books and our experience both the
paranoia the Scarlet Mage would be now
the series then devolves into an all-out
war between factions like the Illuminati
and the skrulls Reid Richards invents a
device that is able to determine who is
and who isn't a scroll that helps the
earth and the hero's overall win because
once you get that mystery solved you can
really dive in now it seems like the
series will pick up in the midst of the
paranoia with government operatives
asking for help of Marvel's heroes so I
wanted to ask some of your guy's opinion
and get your questions answered with
these following queries what will be the
inciting incident of this series will it
be similar to the electorate available
in the comics do we think that there's
going to be a lecture introduced do we
think we're going to do Richards now the
show seems to be Scrolls and him versus
the different group of Scrolls and
humans how do we expect these factions
to break out and with no Reed Richards
in the 616 MCU who do you think could
fill that role or how do you think this
cold war might end holy cow spider
when the clock went away
he was uh flash running so fast the
Earth rotated opposite and it's actually
earlier now than when we started also
one of those Scrolls was written skulls
and it threw me out the entire time
because my brain kept going like don't
say skills don't say skills so I had
like this backup monitor yes I think it
was about 145.
my goal was my goals all right clip it
clip here we put that [ __ ] on social
that's where we um I love those
questions right assuming they do follow
I mean the comic book storyline was
awesome and like is one of the much most
loved kind of comic story lines the last
10 years
um yeah like who replaces the death of
Elektra cause like we already had so
many kind of or
tiny
so far in the MCU but not any that are
like big enough to like set off a big
war what we're gonna say Jessica I'm so
confused what we're talking about so
uh who we think Emilia Clark is is
playing this kind of scroll Princess
um kicks off the kind of secret Invasion
Storyline by being like Elektra yeah by
the same feeling that Elektra was in
fact a scroll the whole time so
basically like having a lead character
the basically the the essence of it is
with the lead character to the scale of
Elektra and using from the comic books
like her getting skewered in the back
which is what they did they paralleled
it having all of that has to feel
impactful so it can't be a supporting
character and we also need someone of
the scientific prowess of Reed Richard
that's already established to design
something that would eliminate that
certain element and the third question I
posited was uh what factions will break
out a la civil war with people believing
each other and how people will cause
that certain like I don't trust the
system situation so factions read and
Electra parallels okay yeah we see who
is it in the in the trailer for secret
Invasion there's that great shot of uh
Nick Fury and somebody else like walking
down like a hallway with shotguns or
something like that is that Roadie
that's with them or who's where oh my
gosh wait what was that John
uh so it's like we have to assume that
like Nick Fury is aligned with one of
the scroll factions right if this is
humans and Scrolls versus other humans
and other Scrolls right we know he's
down with them he's hanging out on their
space station him and Talos are like
body swapping back and forth right like
doing double dates or whatever the hell
um
I mean I have a PTA meeting but I also
have a date with my wife can you take
one of these foreign
but like yeah who would be on the other
side well it seems like the the trailer
kind of sets up maybe Roadie is hitting
the other it's actually to me that
Roadie has known long enough that
there's gonna be a conflict with Nick
Fury no matter what like that scene to
me says Hey I've known about this it
seemed like it was juice worth the
squeeze now there's a conflict and maybe
Roadies like we can't trust these
Scrolls and all theories like yeah at
all I've been I mean maybe yeah and he's
all at all yeah and I like that idea
because also rhodium more by the book
Nick Fury a has been known to bend a lot
of rules for what he thinks is the
greater good and sometimes you're not
sure which side of things he's on it
seems like armor Wars and secret
invasions are our sister shows yeah
which makes me wonder what causes the
invasion based on like the the armor War
situations and I was going to say based
on your third story or your second
question about like who's the genius
scientist that invents the skull
detection device maybe we don't get that
because maybe armor Wars is a de facto
season two of this show and we don't
want that we don't want the scroll issue
to be over we've got to keep that going
and I still think we need the dodc thing
where there's an inherent paranoia where
the the average person doesn't know
whether to trust heroes or not and I
think planting the seeds of that with
Scrolls is important because we've got
Miss Marvel aware the dodc doesn't trust
uh Heroes at all but they're using
children as a way to like get this law
passed right because in the comic books
what happens is is the Civil War law
doesn't pass the circumvia Accords don't
go forward uh in the comics it's
Stanford but that's either but basically
things don't go the way the government
wants to two and then when that falls
apart that same agency comes back and
goes like okay well kids can't be heroes
and since they're minors they're able to
leverage that with this thing called
kamala's law and Kamala Khan ironically
is the one that gets hurt put in
hospital so basically her name is used
against her own friends with the
Thunderbolts and these other characters
uh and that turns into a big conflict of
like okay if you're underage you can't
be a hero and these people get some some
ground covered with this law so I can
see them establishing a dodc hey we
don't know if these heroes are alien or
human hey we don't know if this can be
trusted hey throw out armor Wars and
then a long game when X been coming out
in like five years we've got this
distrust of metahumans
I hate it no I don't hate the I don't
think the theory is bad I think the
theory is right I think that I just
don't I don't want that to happen or do
you want to happen I don't know is it's
just hard for me I don't know and this
is uh this is the nice part of me I just
don't believe that Roadie and the red
they're going to be separated that much
where it's going to become like a Fury
versus Roadie versus all these Scrolls
who are also fighting each other it just
feels like there's too many team-ups
well this the scrolls are also gonna be
a huge part of the Marvels I think
because I think the preschool words
and that's gonna be you know another
giant thing that's happening that
affects the earth I think it you know
the Marvel's ends and it's Earthbound I
think it's a galactic movie that ends
with ramifications and maybe this series
sets up the Marvels in the same way one
division set up Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse demand yes right that's
exactly what I think this is gonna end
in some kind of open-ended like okay we
fought this battle in Manhattan now we
go to the Stars right secret invasion is
so confusing in this way and this is the
reason why I keep getting so mad about
secret invasion is that I'm just like
there is no limit there is no nothing's
grounded there you don't need
justification because people can just
change whenever they want that's the
best right if you love a good Cold War
spy Thriller where you don't know who to
trust or if you love a good John
Carpenter's The Thing or you know
Invasion of the Body Snatchers where you
don't know is this my friend or somebody
the movie's only an hour where this is
gonna be like five films
Espionage right like this I think this
is my biggest trailer out of San Diego
Comic-Con now people have gotten to see
it it's a bit more extended and I think
that like suspense is what the MCU needs
right now yeah I think even though it's
galactic we need something a little bit
more grounded in the humanity like we
want to feel that paranoia and I think
this show looks like winter soldier this
show looks like that 70s Espionage
thriller so even though it's alien
Galactic based we're still going to be
like like I want that one division
feeling back where we we're talking
about like what the hell is going on
exactly yes and I think this show is
going to give us that yeah
it's gonna give this is
giving annoyance yes it's even the best
possible way I certainly back because we
didn't do a good job of answering it if
and I love this idea that they're going
to kill a character of significance yeah
not some new actor not Olivia Coleman's
character somebody like that first
episode they kill somebody we know we've
seen in other properties and like dead
on the ground the face changes to the
green weirdges or whatever of a scroll
um who would it be who are we willing to
throw can we kill Fury
oh you think they kill him for I don't
think I think Fury is already too
untrusted I love this the trailer he's
so tired dude he's so tired he's so done
and just yeah give him that sweet sweet
release that sweet sweet release of
death a long nap yeah I give him that
long long awaited well I mean what if
they do that but it's not Fury it is a
scroll and it's not even Talos it's a
it's a second scroll right Talos is
subcontracting out his Fury uh
impression I think there's gonna be like
a lot of evil squirrels that invade and
I think it's going to be alarming when
good scrolls are even a thing on the
human side because like in the comic
books there aren't a lot of good Scrolls
there are some good Scrolls but overall
they're introduced as villains so I
thought it was really interesting in
Captain Marvel when they were good and
that was a good like you know Twist on
the comic book expectation but now
they've got to double down on that as
well as introduce the comic book version
could we get a group of Heroes facing
off against their mimics
yeah that's what happens
it happened and it made me so upset
because I was was just like it's endless
you can't win well like Jessica Drew was
a scroll for a long time and Jessica
Drew got real and she's like I've been
trapped
you don't know who that like some people
die but they don't change Max so you
don't know who at that moment the camera
holds on their face and we don't it's
like this
yeah I read a brief uh the section or
section of brief Comics a secret
Invasion where it's the Hood and his
faction basically being like we just
need to go help we should go help them
because they're taking over do you know
that comic uh who they killed they
killed another villain member of their
team and everyone was like don't kill
him he's a member of our team but he
actually was a scroll and I would love
to see that situation happen where the
villains come to help and it's like um I
don't trust this guy and like kill him
and going back to like you know Reed
Richards in the comic has this like
machine that could detect who's a scroll
like maybe they don't give us that Deus
Machina but like something right you
know Nick Fury's got some code words
some secret handshakes something so that
he knows you know what I mean so that's
that's the good spy stuff right like the
crow flies at midnight and all the weird
little you know things that actual spies
do yeah seriously
franchises to be made yeah he's going to
be an elephant what if Brody where's
armor was on this uh what if Brody's
contract ends in this either just like
Hey we're gonna I mean that's right uh
don cheadle's kind of saying that Don
Cheadle better not get killed like that
well I mean he's got to do our rewards
so yeah and they have to come to the end
of our reports yeah well and what is
armor okay yes okay all that matters is
Sam Rockwell comes back that's all I
want I know Justin Timberlake what if we
killed Justin Hammer no oh the whole
time well we know who's not dying in
secret Invasion any people that have
been announced for the Thunderbolts any
people that have their own movies or
series coming out after this we really
am just not dying in this show oh thank
God lots of other kamalakon will not be
dying in this show lots of other folks
but who knows who might show up
um very excited where it's high on our
excitement meter for next year there's a
lot of guys Ant-Man I'll be very upset
they can't they can't thank you yeah
no the quantum video will be coming out
before this so like do you think uh pot
Red's like three movies and I'm out kill
me off at the beginning of uh I'd lose
my mind I also feel like it goes secret
Invasion armors which we know but I feel
like the third quiet Trilogy of that is
gonna be cap four I think they described
it as a paranoid Thriller right I think
we go right into the heightened world of
paranoid Thrillers with you know dealing
with Sam Wilson as Captain America and a
certain half America having issues and
stuff you're saying you're gonna kill
samples
I I'm I'm hesitant to invoke this
person's name because they are
persunding on grata in my house film
juice actually has a decent idea first
time ever
um in their life but uh film juice says
how about Fury kills Hill and a bout of
paranoia there's something I think the
show is going to do again that will be
like wild like somebody's like I know
you're a scroll they kill him and they
don't change
I would like that I would I would give
them my entire salary which is zero
dollars I do this for free uh she pays
her rent
um okay uh again we're super Jazzy
there's so much more to talk about we'll
be getting more news More Trailers we'll
Force koi to repeat all this and ever uh
shrinking uh time intervals
um but real quick we want to take a
moment to uh I think the sponsors that
helped bring us uh help us bring you
this show uh which we're very
appreciative of
um hey we all want to take care of our
brains and keep keep our Noggins happy
and healthy and one good way to do that
is through therapy uh but maybe you
don't want to leave at your house to do
therapy you know that's totally
understandable uh thankfully our friends
at betterhelp offer online Therapy
Solutions uh Tommy here on the show has
been very open and honest about his
experience with better help which he's
gotten a lot of value out of it's been
really helpful for him
um like uh better help is online therapy
so you can do it wherever you feel most
comfortable and they offer video phone
and even live chat only therapy sessions
for whatever your preferences are you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to much more affordable
than in-person therapy as well our
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com break room that's
better
h-e-l-p help
dot com slash breakroom
they make us spell it out because it'd
be very easy I'm not the best enunciator
to think it was better health because
it's also helping your health but it's
help okay better help
like yeah TV is Spencer movie
hell yeah
yes yes
um okay thank you to betterhelp again
for sponsoring us all week then real
quick shout out uh to our friends at the
uh newrockstarsmerch.com who um made
this shirt superhero law division I'll
be wearing while I watch She-Hulk
episode are we already up to episode
five spots
um check out all their cool they have a
whole line of She-Hulk shirts uh at
newrockstarsmerch.com including one I
also sometimes wear that says girl boss
yeah I get a lot of look no he doesn't
everyone in the office loves him in that
shirt God this that is my breakdown act
like you like the shirt I love your
breakdowns and I like wearing this shirt
because I feel like it's funny I feel
bad uh it's my breakdowns I write them
and I still don't wear the merch for it
I'm sorry I leave it on my desk I forget
about it and then I wear a horror shirt
instead you guys it's kind of time for a
certain time that's kind of fun but more
mandatory it's mandatory
look at that graphic
oh that wasn't a werewolf sound but I
promise
don't worry Anna we're 72 dollars away
I can't wait for these Salem trials
bark you guys uh mandatory fun today is
very fun because it has to involve
She-Hulk and She-Hulk is very fun and
today's is our predictions as we do do
we have the point score up I don't think
um oh John said he's gonna have the the
totals up tomorrow he got busy today and
didn't have the season-long totals we're
keeping track every week of these
predictions and and the scores I wasn't
here last week so I don't currently know
who's winning but I'm sure it's Tommy
it's like a three-way time it is it's
something crazy yeah I think maybe you
and Brandon and maybe
it might have been pretty bad this
season if we don't win that seafood boil
like I promise you all in the chat we'll
just still use use the company card I
know where Philip hides it uh
yeah oh sorry the cell prompter does say
John was too busy to get our current
scores on the screen but everyone is
incredibly close we'll have it updated
scores for you tomorrow so our first
prediction is Todd revealed to be behind
Titania and or The Wrecking Crew yes
listen I'm tired of these wishy-washy
answers people going back
I don't like it I'm every single one of
these answers I'm planning my flag
and saying not saying yes well this
one's a yes or a no so good okay and
just a quick recap for the audience who
maybe hasn't been following along as
closely with She-Hulk Todd in in that we
got that Montage of uh Jennifer going on
dates yeah he was maybe the creepy one
that I said the second from the end who
called her a specimen father like it was
intriguing I pitched that I think he has
something to do with the black widows
because they still have the same he has
the same ring as uh Direct Golf drag off
uh so I was like maybe he has something
to do with the Romanian yeah and that
actor has been doing press for this
series so it seems like he's a bigger
part than we than just a kind of one-off
unseen joke role so uh Anna very
confident that he is behind something
bad Jessica are you saying no maybe not
Wrecking Crew but maybe something else
behind something bad but is revealed to
be behind Titania and or The Wrecking
Crew that's that's hard one because I
don't think he's behind Titania but I do
think he's probably Behind The Wrecking
Crew okay do you think Titania is
Titania's behind
strangely worded
um I think Titania is behind GLK and H
uh I was alerted so she could actually
oh
we're gonna see who's a werewolf today
Peter well I mean we'll have to wait for
them no no okay oh my God sometimes
voice is changing my shirt does say Easy
Bake Oven thank you for noticing what
okay yeah what and I do have something
to say are you okay no please
I think
is there a Yorkie in the studio I don't
know what that is are you okay I'm sorry
I feel fine please keep time okay okay
wow uh I'll say yeah he is revealed to
be behind The Wrecking Crew I did what
what
is this a were puppy
you're on the left side and I'm on the
road
oh God oh God please I hope okay guys oh
yeah are you all right good did I take
my daily nap again
standard issue now oh wow okay
that was the cutest scariest thing I've
ever experienced rom-com taking a Lon
Chaney movie I'm gonna say yes for the
first one yes officially geez
uh I have no memory I don't know
um
oh the second one is oh what's the
question uh you guys I don't know did
you did you did you predict one I did
yeah I said yes I think we're straight
down the line everybody's saying yes
whether it be a mention of Jennifer's
blood
because I think if they harp on it too
much then it'll be obvious and I think
we need an episode that doesn't deal
with it so I'm gonna say no I think yes
because last episode we didn't talk
about it because that was episode three
that big Wrecking Crew attacker yeah and
then now we're on the fourth episode
where it was all about the Mystic Arts
and so I'm like I think we're gonna get
back into it so I'll say yes I'm Gonna
Keep now but I like your head we're all
agreeing it will come up in the series
this specifically is it gonna come up
this episode yeah that is both you guys
have good points I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say yes I'm I'm on the same page with
Jessica there that they went away from
it so maybe now it's about time to come
back
um 50 50. I'm still sure
there's nothing more attractive than
someone stubbornly just laying it on the
line and not changing their mind and
being absolutely certain they're right
I'm dating in L.A everyone
Jennifer's blood Jennifer's Body will we
see another Asgardian because and I
guess we should should clarify because
we saw the elf that was from new Asgard
even though she is not as uh you can be
from Asgard and not be what the
asgardians are you know what I'm saying
yeah so uh we saw her but I'm saying
like the wrecking Cruise gear if we saw
the wrecking Cruise gear that's always
Guardian Tech I wouldn't count that as C
in another
game who originated from Asgard or a new
Asgard right what
John is yelling off screen
John is saying that would count the
wrecking Crews tools would count if
somebody utters the word Asgard or
Asgardian we're going to count that is
that right John yeah okay okay so if
someone mentions along those lines we
are counting the two time maybe we've
gone to the Asgardian well twice already
so maybe we won't do it again right
they've they've gone to uh the Mystic
Arts right they've gone to Asgard maybe
they'll be instead they'll be a mention
of a shield wrench and we haven't really
had so far maybe I think I'm gonna say
yes because I think it's easy to just be
like name off a lift this list of places
and just say Asgard in the sentence sure
yeah even as a joke because I know
because I I kind of like where your
head's at I think if we keep going to
Asgard it'll feel like this is uh I
think we need to expand the world not
focus on the one part of the world so
I'm gonna say no yeah yeah I like Fray
girl boldly just claim no no explanation
needed no
there's three notches yes and we're
we're collecting the answers from
Brandon and Tommy and Erica wusu and
producer John and everybody who uh
appears on the show and we're keeping
again a season-long tally there uh again
check on Friday is when the break when
the breakdowns comes on Friday because I
have to tape a breakdown for barbarians
the number one movie at the box office
is last weekend the horror movie
Barbarian Jessica's also doing a
breakdown of that this week keep an eye
out for that early next week I think
it's yeah Monday or Tuesday
um lots of cool stuff and real quick we
want to shout out a couple folks in the
chat match143 saying Anna wear puppy
um your puppy that's where uh Peter so
funny Zach uh you need Dad jokes I'm
your dude uh thank you Peter for sending
in that healthy Super Chat uh Jacob
Beach said what if Dane Whitman's
grandfather who left him the ebony blade
is one of the monster hunters in
werewolf by night
that's a good point we don't know that
werewolves by night is taking place in
the modern right time no and also
because we've only seen like what black
and white and all things black and white
are at least 60 years old right and
that's how I play the game it's got the
TVA in it that's true time travel time
travel is it in time because time is
irrelevant yeah and Eric's breakdown of
that trailer that came out on the
channel today kind of points out maybe
this is in some kind of like void middle
middle realm some of the exterior shots
have like an MC Escher Vibe almost like
yeah headquarters and you know who first
appeared in werewolf by night night
that's right and they're fighting around
hieroglyphics and where puppy appeared
for them that's right favorite
appearance we didn't know at the time he
was aware puppy we just thought he was a
dog but um you know was it was is it
ain't Ein I apologize so much was there
comment regarding um I love y'all but
your blind spot is not thinking about
Agents of Shield when it comes to all
this Marvel's been pretty open about the
Scrolls my money is on lmds being the
twist to meld mine we did introduce lmds
in an Iron Man movie uh way back in the
day with Coulson that was disguster was
that an Avengers movie might have been
Avengers one anyway lmds are Canon so
there is an opportunity to have lmds in
there there Ein uh and you're right ages
Shield is absolutely a blind spot also
for the MCU because they don't seem to
make it all Cannon okay we'll see we'll
see uh it seems like they make Agents of
Shield Cannon when convenient or when it
plays into their narrative which is fine
we want good stories right uh the MJ
2997 Kermit the Frog confirmed as a
skrull what
I've lost all trust in the market here
uh you guys do not bet on me on these
Productions
I've been so wrapped in the horror that
is happening this week next week in all
of October the She-Hulk I'm like oh no
I'm being silly once Anna's near me I
just become too silly with my
Productions where's this goofy goobers
Goofy Goobers print that shirt
um Newton Master's saying can we get a
trivia night between koi and Voss
everyone always trying to pit me against
Vaughn
doesn't have to be a competition what if
or what if it's a trivia night were you
guys asking
um that actually would be really fun
maybe the you the audience
a trivia night here
um I'm so bad at trivia genuinely
horrible it takes me 20 like minutes to
recognize what the question was and then
they're like bring your sheet up and I'm
like
at a Ritz where I can argue my point
that I am at like my brain doesn't do it
right it takes too long for me to
there's just so much in there I'm so dog
data yeah you have to do a very specific
kind of memory names and dates and stuff
like that SpongeBob trivia I could
probably murder like I've got all my
Comics so I'm at like 17 000. I think I
just said 17 000 Comics uh and they're
mostly on the East Coast but like I can
tell my mom what third of the long box
it's in what the cover looks like and
which panel I'm looking forward to see
like the quality that's up here but I
can't tell you like necessarily what
year Moon night came out like it's just
it's always this year koi
luckily we're 41 away from that so we
can all stay safe okay a couple other
folks we want to shout out
uh how about koi first Philip arm
wrestling uh what was wrong with me arm
wrestling very good what about just
handshaking the decent push-up contest
we can coin boss I got you Eric let's go
oh God how about we do things that are
not athletic you can eat the most tacos
I have a disturbing gastric capacity uh
I've never lost a kneading contest so
who can adopt the most cats in 30
minutes
I'm just saying oh we got match one for
three saying happy early birthday koi
again midnight tonight he'll be
celebrating uh and if anyone harms a
heron in his head we Riot well if I wish
werewolf it's allowed it's a lot of fun
werewolf yeah technically I didn't harm
Anna I harmed a were puppy that had
emerged uh you were really bad at
killing that we're supposed
some green flags uh but uh we thank you
all for watching today everybody in the
chat everybody who joined us a couple
quick things to plug in addition to the
videos that are coming out on the new
rockstars Channel real quick also if
you're watching right now hit the like
button on this video we want a crazy
good like ratio also did you know that
lots of people I think the majority of
people that watch any rockstars video
are not subscribed to new rock stars if
you're watching you made it this part in
the video subscribe also if you
subscribe watching the break room you'll
be more likely to see break room
notifications like when we're going live
and when a new video is posted so
that'll be good presumably you enjoyed
what you watched uh and you would like
to see more of it uh also next Tuesday a
scant six days from now we're
celebrating our 100th episode whoa and
we might be dressed very nice oh we
might be dressed to impress maybe just
me and maybe just me it's a big deal yes
we're pulling out all the stops 100 cats
yeah 100 cats
we'll be we'll be neck deep and dander
um so come back join us next Tuesday uh
we appreciate you all have a good rest
of your day we'll see you soon
yes happy birthday card she's coming
back out